today more than 10 000 ambulance workers
have voted to go on strike they feel
that a four percent pay award is just
simply not keeping up with inflation
it's a real terms can't do you have
sympathy with them well clearly we want
to make sure that um all workers
especially for public sector workers are
doing really important work like our
ambulance workers get get a fair pay
um uh settlement and that's why we've
um accepted the pay-per-view work that's
been done by the pay review body who've
looked at all the different factors and
it is a challenge clearly it's a
challenge because I can understand why
people can see their prices going up and
want their wages to match we see people
in the private sector the equally is
challenged and their prices their wages
aren't going up but we've got to be
realistic we've got to make sure that
first of all we can afford it in terms
of the public sector the money that's
coming out the treasury I think if you
looked at the nurses settlement for
example it would equate to something
like nine billion pounds on the NHS
budget that's got to come from somewhere
but also you risk stoking inflation as
well at the same time though um you know
ambulance workers that's an acutely
stressful job I mean I can imagine how
how difficult it is we've seen the
record waiting times we've seen the
stories about people who've been treated
in ambulances outside hospitals because
they can't get a bed it's not too much
to ask that their pay package shouldn't
be shrinking at this time no these are I
say these are difficult times that's a
real you know especially for ambulance
workers because of those extra pressures
that are on them at the moment in the
NHS and of course at this time of year
anyway regardless of picking up still
from from covert but no I come back to
the point and it is difficult to to
think through when you are worrying
about paying your bills and worrying
about uh the the cost of living and what
you're seeing in all the newspapers and
of course all the broadcast and
everything like that professors from
everywhere across the world but the
problem is if you start stoking
inflation then these pressures will last
longer inflation is supposed to be a
global challenge that's what you guys
keep telling usually it's all about how
much nurses get paid no it is because
well look if you think about the bank of
England the bank of England look has one
lever to tackle inflation interest rates
so it puts interest rates up and down
and so basically if inflation continues
because there is more money coming into
the economy
um then the bank has one labor to pull
interest rates so actually by giving
them more money now what you're finding
is their mortgage rates will carry on
going up later and so it's trying to get
it is a real fine balance that's what
you're trying to say you know
effectively overall we've got to make
something that that is Affordable is
proportionate but is at least as Fair as
possible you know you've just been
talking about the financial pressures
about what affordable what isn't is it
affordable for the private school should
continue to be accepted from va2
look I think this is a really uh this is
a debate that I can understand the
politics around it you know you saw
kirst armor talking today about
Winchester
um frankly if you take vat off private
schools now without the thought about
how you how you Model Behavior change
you'll see a load of schools a load of
schools close you'll see people taking
their children out out of Independent
Schools it won't be Winchester Harrow
eating those kind of big Elite schools
that everybody always thinks about it'll
be the middle of the road schools
especially prep schools where and those
those people will have to go into State
education so what you're doing now where
is kirst armor again understandably for
political reasons says well we're
subsidizing them by 20 well guess what
you'll be subsidizing by 100 if they're
actually moving to the states I'll be
honest I I am struggling to understand
this I've been fully right because if
you're a state school you have to act
within your budget all the time
inflation has meant sudden changes to
State School budgets as well right and
so what do they do they have 30 pupils
in the class they have to ask teaching
assistants they have to scrap music
lessons surely the same would happen for
private schools you would just cut your
cloth you'd make budget savings just
like in the states so what you have
that's why I was talking about those
middle type schools actually because
what you already have in the independent
sector in parts of the independent
sector when you get outside Elite
Schools they're already Under Pressure a
lot of businesses
I wonder what what you're finding is
that a lot of prep schools for example
although go up to 13. there is no there
is a dwindling market for schools in
this country that go up to 13 and so
they're all starting to Pivot and change
and what you're finding at some schools
are failing some schools are closing
already some schools are being taken
over
um but I come back to the point that if
you've got a school with small
relatively small role numbers and then
they start going back into the state
system not only do those businesses fail
because they are as I say businesses
just slash Charities however we want to
turn them then you have the uh
um state school you're adding pressure
into the state schools system they want
to then they will need to build schools
where are they going to find the land to
build the schools it will be the old
Independent School sites that have just
closed down so you effectively
cross-funding in that way so you're not
going to get a major economic benefit I
just want to have a look um at a graph
that I think shows some of the
difference in per-pupil funding so
whether it's fees charge private schools
or if it is the things that they get
from the government from the state
sector now this is the change in school
funding uh per pupil you can see the red
line of course the state schools the
blue line is private schools and
according to the ifs 6 500 pounds more
is spent per pupil in the private sector
than the state sector are you really
saying funding can't be you know
squeezed in the private sector if you
look at this graph what I'm saying what
I'm saying is that the Zone intending
consequences I'm just I'm not saying
that you can't make any changes because
bearing in mind the the vat changes that
you're talking about my understanding
and it may go as well but I think that
although they get the 20 percent vat
they're not allowed to claim back so
actually if they if you remove that from
them and they go they've become a Pure
business rather than the charity they
will be able to claim their vat back so
again you're not going to get the quite
that Gap closed that you think you're
going to get it's all about unintended
consequences for me
I was hoping you might be able to clear
something up for you on onshore winds
but be completely honest I'm finding
quite hard to keep up with what the
government position is we know of course
British seen like wanted to continue
with the effect of ban or new uh onshore
uh wind he's now of course coming to
pressure from Rebels including Boris
Johnson and Liz truss so what is the
current position then well I'm in the
current position is is a is aware the
you know the fact that there is you have
to have Community by and you have
Community consent there is there's there
has been no change but clearly this
amendment's coming in there's a lot of
people that have some people have an
overarching view that they want to see
more onshore wind but there are a number
of people that have signed that
amendment that have constituency issues
in particular and you know we're in the
middle of a process as ever uh where
whereas um you know the government will
be listening and we'll be talking to
those people to see where we can land it
what's your own view because you know
Grant shops has sat here saying it's a
nice saw then you get other conservative
MPS you say look this is a really cheap
way of getting green energy what's your
view will it I can see both sides
because there's not a lot called
Financial wind turbines in something
cheap so I've not had that direct
responsibility in my part of Southwest
London as a constituency MP to be fair
but if you look at and I can understand
the appeal but I can also understand the
difficulty of living with one of those
or the prospect of having an onshore
wind turbine it's important however we
do it that we take people with us it's
you know we're doing great things with
offshore wind
um I actually gave planning permission
the last things I did as business
Minister for size of our city and so I
noticed that the government has uh has
given the go ahead for that it's getting
the mix right that's that's the key
thing and now there's another story that
I wanted to ask you about well I've got
you um Prince William's godmother uh
resigned after asking negozi philania
where she really came from at a
reception at Buckingham Palace and when
Miss Fellaini said that she was British
lady Susan Hussey said I can see I'm
going to have a challenge getting you to
say where you're from
she has um it stood aside from her job
as a result of that is it an example of
racism
I think there's a lot of casual racism I
say that someone is half Burmese that uh
you know there's often this kind of idea
that uh people say yeah but where are
you really from
um you know that's uh takes a bit of
unfortunately we're still having to
educate people so you think it is an
example of casual risk you know I think
there is this casual sort of a approach
sometimes which you have to be careful
because uh you know I'm all for free
speech but um but why on Earth would you
want to offend someone right that way
and you can understand
um why she's offended by it yeah yeah
that makes a lot of sense definitely
yeah I mean look I mean as I say you
know when I was growing up I was a you
know I don't consider myself
particularly dark but I had a slightly
dark skin than than some of my friends
and they knew my Burmese background and
uh you know there's a lot of casual
racism in that you see was that a school
that you yeah yeah uh and then it's and
and then some of that stuff and stuff
tends to get written offers uh oh but
it's just banter and then um you know
this instance I it's the first time I've
I've I've heard about this this um
example that you that you put in front
of me but as I say from everything
you've said it just sounds like a it can
easily be swept away as just a casual
conversation but I was just interested
not really appropriate tell me to you
know go away if you want but if you
wanted to talk a bit about what happened
at school then you know oh no there's
just you know for me it was name
pointing it was it was children really I
think exploring their boundaries I'm not
I didn't have a bad time no no crikey
there's no wild I would ever describe
myself as having a uh you know
discriminatory childhood but it was just
it was name-calling it was it was sort
of banter when actually if I wanted to
kick back and I did every now and again
people realized so I I'm very lucky in
that regard but you can you can as you
say from your own experiences but also
just looking at you know the world
around you you can understand how
someone would react to what as you said
it's casual racism yeah because look I
think I'm really proud of my Burmese
Heritage which is why I do talk about it
a lot and I and I'm sure
um yeah this lady that is proud of hers
um and it's important that uh
you don't counter that the the uh but
but on the other hand and I'm glad
people are interested in people's
Heritage there's Ways and Means and
that's not what she was saying yeah yeah
exactly there's Ways and Means about
about going about inquiring shall we say
thank you very much for being on the
show it's been really interesting to
talk to you today pleasure